[Musique]
que ce soit pour travailler pour
communiquer pour vous informer vous vous
y connectez tous les jours mais
savez-vous vraiment comment fonctionne
Internet dans ce grand angle on va
remonter le fil du réseau des réseaux de
la conception au déploiement dans les
communes jusqu'au raccordement des
abonnés et on commence à valdaon bonjour
C alors ici à valdon c'est le syndicat
mix d' très haut débit qui est chargé du
déploiement du réseauit comme dans une
grande partie du département du dou oui
sur à peu près
483 communes qui regroupent environ
243000 habitants principalement dans le
secteur rural donc des zones rurales
alors le réseau il arrive d'où cette
fibre elle arrive d'où à la base alors
là on est en gros le réseau part ce
qu'on appelle un data center qui est à
Besançon la lumière transite jusque par
exemple jusqu'à Valdahon et arrive ce
qu'on appelle un central optique nœud de
raccordom optique c'est un peu le cœur
du réseau et ce central va permettre
d'allumer de fournir la lumière à aux
habitants de valdon mais également
quelques communes aux alentours donc
c'est la première porte d'entrée c'est
le cœur du réseau c'est un lieu ultra
sensible oui ultr sensible sécurisé il y
a que les équipes d'exploitants qui
peuvent rentrer dans dans ce type de
bâtiment puisque les équipements sont
comment à protéger et nécessitent peu
d'intervention normalement il a tout un
tracé qui a été conçu à la base
effectivement en fait nous on est parti
d'une feuille blanche parce qu'il y
avait pas de réseau initial sur le
département du dou donc il a fallu
effectivement constituer une
ingénierie constituer ce qu'on appelle
un réseau de collecte et par la suite et
bien comme je disais la lumière va aller
au niveau du sousrépartiteur optique va
voir tout de suite
exactement donc cyil la lumière le
réseau arrive depuis ces câbles oui tout
à fait du cœur de réseau qu'on a vu
juste à côté voilà donc on arrive sur
les ce qu'on appelle les BA optiques la
lumière arrive ici où on retrouve les
les équipements des opérateurs et la
lumière est distribuée ensuite à chaque
abonné via ce qu'on appelle ces tiroirs
de distribution où chaque an
chaque entreprise est parfaitement
référencée pour distribuer la lumière
donc là vous savez exactement vers
quelles habitations le réseau est
distribuer tout à fait et et en gros une
armoire comme ça va être en capacité de
distribuer 500 600
[Musique]
abonnés donc ici on est dans le hall
d'un immeuble tout neuf et la fibre
arrive dans ce placard tout à fait AR on
arrive de la rue et le câ va arriver au
niveau de ce boîtier euh et euh ce
niveau du boîtier qui permet aujourd'hui
de venir alimenter chaque appartement
tout simplement chaque logement va être
ensuite alimenté euh et c'est ici que
parfois le bblesse qu' a parfois des
difficultés de raccordement des mal
façon effectivement un peu sur la partie
raccordement on a quelques soucis euh
aujourd'hui alors pas trop sur ce type
d'installation parce que là on est sur
ce qu'on appelle un précablage tout a
été prévu norm on n' pas trop de souci
c'est parfois sur des raccordements
abonnés un peu plus classiques il y a
beaucoup de malheureusement beaucoup de
de
sous-traitan un peu incontrôlé pas
suffisamment formé et on a quelques
soucis de mal façon donc vous avez agi
vous syndicat là-dessus oui
effectivement on essaie d'agir au niveau
national pour essayer de de de faire
bouger un peu les acteurs du Télécom
pour que réguler un peu réguler pour que
ça soit beaucoup plus contrôlé qu'on ait
beaucoup plus de visibilité que les gens
soient formés ceux qui interviennent et
qu'on ait beaucoup moins de soucis et
que la fibre arrive bien et exactement
il a pas de problème de connexion tout à
fait Cyril aujourd'hui combien d'abonnés
sont raccordables à votre réseau fibre
et bien sur 141000 qui était le projet
initial on est à peu près à 138000
aujourd'hui et sur ces ouais logement
raccordé raccordable et on est à peu
près à 70000 clients donc des personnes
qui sont effectivement raccordé au
réseau donc ça fait à peu près plus de
90 % du territoire couvert largement
largement oui et c'est un chantier
d'envergure parce que vous avez commencé
il y a 10 ans tout à fait 10 ans pour
déployer ce réseau oui c'est 10 ans d'un
chantier industriel avec bien sûr
beaucoup de partenaires on a déployé à
peu plus de de 7000 km de de câble en
souous-terrain ou en aérien l'aérien
représente aujourd'hui à peu près 50 %
du déploiement c'est un lourd
investissement un lour investissement de
près de 220 millions d'euros porté
naturellement par les collectivités le
le
département les
intercommunalités la région
naturellement et l'État qui aussi nous a
aidé dans ce projet avec parfois des
défis techniques des difficultés il a
fallu raccorder par exemple le château
de jou ça ça a dû être un chantier
énorme oui c'est un chantier
effectivement un peu emblématique parce
que qu'un accès extrêmement difficile
pas d'infrastructure existante donc il a
fallu
reconstituer une tranchée des conduites
souterraines pour pouvoir alimenter
le château de jou avec un coup forcément
qui était assez assez conséquent ça
c'est c'est des exemples plutôt
spectaculaires merci beaucoup Cyrine on
a vu dans cet épisode que et bien
parfois les collectivités publiques
créent le réseau Internet et puis il y a
aussi des opérateurs privés qui
déploient leur propre réseau on va le
voir demain dans le deuxème
[Musique]
volet